amanda knox might have been forgiven if
she never returned to italy the place
where she was accused in a sensational
murder trial and spent almost four years
in prison before being acquitted of all
charges but knox is back there this
morning for an event focusing on italy's
criminal justice system and what happens
when a case like hers is tried in the
media Seth Doane has the story
Natalia it even got an emotional Amanda
Knox spoke entirely in Italian this
morning of her love for Italy saying she
made this return trip because she used
to feel at home in this beautiful
country and hopes to again at times she
fought back tears I'm very nervous she
said forgive me she explained the
confusing rounds of questioning after
the murder and blasted how media
characterized and dehumanized her I was
depicted as wily psychopathic dirty and
a drug abusing [ __ ] she said guilty
until proven innocent
since returning to Italy this week Knox
has been in the media spotlight much
like it was all the way back to 2007
when her roommate Meredith Kercher was
killed this story an American students
studying abroad charged with the murder
and sexual assault of her British
roommate was devoured by the public and
while she was ultimately exonerated
she's been portrayed as both victim and
monster and acknowledged today she
remains of suspect figure if she can
continue the way that she is and create
a new persona for herself in the eyes of
the public
then eventually I think she'll be
accepted
sunny Jacobs an American and her husband
Peter Pringle were called heroes by
Amanda Knox today they understand
firsthand the battle to rebuild her
image both Jacobs and Pringle were once
on death row and both exonerated in
murder cases this shadow follows you for
the rest of your life how because
there's always a question about there's
always a doubt the doubt is what are you
really innocent yes
yes today knock set out to publicly
address those doubts saying she'd been
thinking lately of the prosecutor
hospital I hope you will be able to see
me not as a monster but just Amanda
adding to the audience I have the same
hope for you today countless writers
reporters and filmmakers have tried to
tell her story today was about Amanda
Knox telling her story herself for CBS
this morning Saturday Seth Doane Modena
Italy
yeah in so many ways she had her
identity taken away from her during the
course of that yeah and there's power
when you can tell your own story yes
this is very much the same circumstances
that the Central Park five found
themselves in after being exonerated
defined by the media in the case but
never only finally being allowed to
speak themselves